Election meddling
Fellas, I need 11,000 votes give me a break
The mishandling of classified documents...
It’s an unprecedented day in American history
...and the falsifying of business records
Alvin Bragg is investigating former president Trump regarding a hush money payment
Just some of the 91 criminal charges facing Donald Trump
I am a victim of one of the great political smear campaigns...
...in the history of our country
But how much jeopardy is he really in?
Across four criminal cases...
...Trump faces 44 federal and 47 state charges, all of them felonies
First up, Trump will face independent special prosecutor Jack Smith’s indictment
The attack on our nation’s Capitol on January 6th 2021...
...was an unprecedented assault on the seat of American democracy
Courts will consider four charges...
...including conspiracy to defraud the United States
The indictment alleges Trump set out to sabotage the constitutional process...
...by manipulating the election in several states
You don’t concede when there’s theft involved
And exploiting violence at the Capitol to delay certification of the vote
That same month, Manhattan’s top prosecutor Alvin Bragg...
...begins a separate trial
Trump is charged with 34 counts of falsifying business records...
Donald Trump has become the first former United States president...
...to face criminal charges
...in order to cover up an alleged $130,000...
...hush money payment to porn star Stormy Daniels
Next up, Mr Smith will be back to bring a separate case
Alleging Trump kept secret documents long after he left the White House
He’ll face 40 charges, including 31 counts of violations of the Espionage Act...
...of 1917
They alleged Trump stored boxes with classified documents...
...all over the place in Mar a Lago, frankly...
...including some detailing America’s nuclear secrets
Finally, Trump will face prosecutor Fani Willis in court...
...but his trial date hasn’t been set yet
The court will consider 13 charges, including racketeering...
...a law originally designed to target the Mafia
The statute ties 19 co-defendants together...
The grand jury believes they were part of the illegal effort...
...to overturn the result of Georgia’s 2020 presidential election
...and alleges Trump was the boss of this criminal enterprise
Central to the case will be Trump’s...
...alleged attempt to put pressure on Georgia’s secretary of state...
...to find the exact number of votes needed to win
Four of Trump’s co-defendants have now taken plea deals...
...so the evidence is mounting against him
All this before even mentioning two ongoing civil trials in New York
But what will this litany of allegations do to his political campaign?
The clashes between Trump’s campaign diary and his court appearances...
...like the one on January 15th...
...where Trump is due at a Republican caucus and a civil trial simultaneously...
...may turn the 2024 election into a crusade to keep him out of prison
But even if Trump is found guilty, it’s unlikely he would see...
...the inside of a prison cell before the election
When you go to bed at night, do you worry about going to jail?
No, I don’t, really
Legal appeals are unlikely to conclude by November...
...and if he takes the White House for a second term...
...Trump could even attempt to pardon himself
This trial is a total witch hunt
Incredibly even if Trump is convicted before the election...
...there is nothing preventing him running for office from behind bars
By posing as a victim of political persecution...
...Trump has made his campaign about the cases against him...
...leveraging the trials to galvanise his base...
...which increases pressure on his own party to back him
If former President Trump is convicted in a court of law...
...would you still support him as your party’s choice?
Please raise your hand if you would
It’s working
Trump is likely to be the next Republican nominee, and his polling...
...only improved as the indictments were filed
Trump now has the biggest lead over his 2024 Republican challengers
Whatever happens in Trump’s court cases...
...it’s clear he will play the outcome to his political advantage
Far from damaging his campaign, Trump’s legal storms are helping it